what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am in
leicester square and we are interviewing
people about this topic feminism is a
hate group we are going to see what the
people of london think before i start do
not forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification bell that we
are going to be notified of my daily
videos while you're at it sign up for
our memberships for our exclusive behind
the scenes perks
okay let's get started
[Music]
okay um
do you
so so we do discussions with people on
the street i'd love to have a
conversation with you
no i just i want to know is it is he
is what what's your uh
reason
what's my reason here here sit i'll tell
you i said don't worry
okay um because the thing is we're just
having like the reason we came was to
get discussions like man make a decision
like why are you why are you coming up
to me and asking to be a part of my
video and asking me these questions if
you're not going to be in it sit down or
don't sit down just like we came here we
only have so much time
but if if you want to sit down i'd love
to have a discussion with you yeah yeah
i just want to know yeah yeah okay okay
okay okay okay
you wanna sit
another one it's like these grown ass
men do you wanna talk on camera or do
you not want to talk at all
like i either either sit down or i need
to move on to the next one what do i
mean it's a hate group against men
it's yeah it's not about equality
like women hate men that are feminists
yeah come on
you can come on i have a hundred
thousand subscribers this is the perfect
place like sir do you think i have all
day
like are you gonna sit down are you just
gonna talk to me i don't argue for free
okay
yeah yeah come on come on
everyone's been
feminist about it
right so first of all okay be careful
okay right we're not too far away from
old compton street if a feminist sees
you holding that sign she'll come over
and punch you in the face to tell you
how innocent she is okay
okay so so i think i think feminism is a
hate group i think they actually hate
men i don't think it's about equality i
think in 2022 as a woman i have nothing
to fight for today this is my opinion
i'd love to hear what yours is right
what you're feeling
is true okay
okay
feminism has been changed and corrupted
but so has people
positives whisper negatives shout
so we tend to see negatives first so no
matter which group you're in
negatives will always be
prominent in your head so when you look
around the world all you see is that's
negative that's negative
whatever whatever whatever so you live
in a world of negativity
and that makes people angry
and that leads to hate and other things
so why do you think that is why do you
think um as women we focus on um
like the hate rather because we live in
the freest societies ever in history
there are two motivational forces
survival reproduction
survival fear negative get away from me
love positive come towards me okay
positive negative it's very simple but
we twist we love what we fear fear what
we love
and we twist
by nature everything twists the earth
goes around the sun blah blah blah
so so negative shout
beauty whispers they both talk
simultaneously so we always hear the
negative the shout over the whisper
but the whisper's always there if you've
got faith and hope then the whisper's
always there if you haven't because the
shouting is so loud then everything is
darkness black negativity anger height
what would you like to see from feminism
like in the future
from everyone
because if we're talking equality from
everyone because feminists don't
actually want equality they just want
equality when it benefits us i was born
in 67 summer of love i was raised
through the bra burning and the
independent woman and
right
and
i've always been raised by strong women
i got my testicles from my father but
i've got my bollocks from my mum
yeah
yeah yeah no no i agree i think like
like so being passionate and having
strength and tenacity shouldn't be a bad
thing yet it is looked upon as a bad
thing now because it's a more sheep-like
environment so the people that are more
fearful worried hateful negative stand
out more
in a peaceful crowd than they would do
when everyone's lively yeah no i don't
think it's the i don't even think the
majority of women are feminists to be
honest the most women i know like don't
identify as a feminist because that that
group has
is like they're just so man-hating like
i love men i grew up around brothers
okay
um
some people
uh want to be dominated
right on one level uh but then hate
themselves on another level and they
build up their own internal battle
their own yin yang um
negatives tend to win
unfortunately
well thank you for coming by i
appreciate it i appreciate it i needed
someone to get the ball rolling so this
is great
thank you
the problems are larger yeah humanity
yeah i agree we do to each other look at
what we do to the planet look at what we
do to ourselves what was your name and
do you have any links you want to plug
do you have any like instagram youtube
okay
jason human
okay okay thank you all right we well
good luck bye
what a nice man see that that's the type
of guy i'm looking for to sit down have
a nice civil conversation
let's see who's next
you you're my guy i've been looking for
you
come on come on
come sit come sit
um
hi
come sit
no no okay
you got an opinion
come on
okay so what's your name gloria i'm
pearl nice to meet you
so um i think feminism is a hate group
because i think that it tears down men
and i i think they just advocate for
women and they advocate for women at the
cost of men okay so you think it's
detrimental to women nowadays
i think i think it's always been
detrimental
um okay and the reason being like they
push things like the pay gap when the
pay gap doesn't even exist
for women so they're they're actively
tearing down men to like build women up
and what do you think about like the
household situation
which one household so right now in the
current times a lot more women are
independent
and then i've i've read somewhere that
they're saying that um
feminism is destroying actual the
household because it's making more women
be more independent i think there's
something about men becoming redundant
why do you like to gather information
well i just think it lies to women
because it tells us to like chase a bag
and you know chase a career don't
prioritize family and then we end up
single childless and alone
and i think they do that at the cost of
men like most feminists i know they
don't they just they disdain
so like what about this new movement i
have him not hyper megan but like the um
was it called again
what's this thing that we're
leveling up
leveling up yes
what do you mean by leveling up women
are now we've been told to go and get
men who are more high high net worth
high level so they can be treated have a
soft life
treated better not chase the bag like
financially take care of the home
what do you think of that because that
i've read is that that's more against
feminism because i was reading something
that said feminism is detrimental to
women as well
so we need to go back to how it was
um i think people should be free to
choose what they wanna i i feel like
they should be free to choose what they
wanna choose
but um i i think when you go when you
tell women to make a lot of money and
then only go after men that make more
money than you it leaves you as a side
piece
because
what percentage of men make uh six
figures do you think not a lot i think
it's less than like because the average
in the uk is 36 000 or 36 something so
how much men are actually making lesser
in like big cities like london and stuff
like that yeah yeah so feminism is
telling you to like chase this career
when
like and then
you're gonna have a guy waiting for you
at the end of it but men aren't
attracted to that so can i ask you a
question so what would you say people
were like you're just being like you
have internalized misogyny
[Music]
people do say that a lot um
and i would say that most people that
say that like have a victim mindset
where they just think the world is
against them and i think as a woman i'm
at an advantage rather than a
disadvantage that is very interesting
yeah no i love talking to you what i've
got going on with my sister oh no that's
okay thank you but no we're sitting down
do you have any like any socials you
want to tag yeah instagram yeah follow
me
hot guys
hot guys hotties
it's glory love89 are you a feminist
do you know what yeah i think to be
honest i'm a meist
so what's most beneficial for me
that is what i am
so i'm not gonna say i have not used my
own privileges to help me get certain
things yes i have okay
i've been the damsel in distress many
times but then i'm like no go women so
i'm a mist
thank you so much you're such a good
sport
yeah she was chill i liked her okay what
do you think of feminism
um
it's really i don't know it's i think
it's made to just break man's balls if
you allow me to say excuse my language
but uh
i don't believe there is such a thing as
feminism because
that dude like feminism these days
they're all complaining about men
getting more paid and this and that but
this is the only one percent
of men that they're actually doing good
in life they're getting good jobs and
everything but still like if you see the
army
slash
i don't know like
cold miners stuff like that like the all
the hard jobs they're man-made yeah i
don't want to do them yeah exactly
exactly so like yeah so like when you
say like when you see women they're more
like
office jobs for women or like
nurses like teachers stuff like that but
like you guys should be paid more for
harder jobs that makes sense well it is
happening now i know so technically we
get a little bit more money than you
guys do but
i think we're worth it do you think that
um
women should march the streets for male
only fans models and strippers that
don't get paid the same
oh
no
no they shouldn't why don't we do that
we want equality don't we yeah why don't
we march the street for men yeah but see
when you speak like desires like sexual
desire it's more like
like everyone knows what men want to see
strippers and stuff like that no one
want to see naked men
no
my point is like women will talk about
the pay gap all day when it comes to
like the one percent the ceos but but
they don't talk about the pay gap
between like male and female models
between male and female male only fans
models be male and female strippers i
feel like you're on outside yeah of
course
i have my sign
yeah no no it's true it's true yeah
they're only talking about
why they feel that we beating them on
while they feel that they're worse at
and they're not really saying the real
facts which is like they're only
comparing what the things that we do
good
and they're not good at and they're not
comparing the stuff that they're good at
and we're not good at well it's almost
like we only look for equality when it
benefits us but not when it but not when
it benefits like not when it's at the
cost of that exactly exactly thank you
and by the way if you if you check like
even
prison capacities like there's more men
than women
exactly
men get three times the amount of
sentencing for the same crime for the
same crime exactly like if if let's say
just this building went on fire
for some for some [ __ ] up reason i'll
go out wait for the women and the kids
to go out first and then i could save my
life like it's just
why do you think the feminists are
silent about these issues i did not
silence they just you know the one i see
in one i don't see you know
they pretend to not see because
obviously that's what they want that's
why they want to talk about like oh yeah
women do this women do that and they
just want us to feel bad for them
but actually i think life is just good
for women let's be honest i think i'm at
an advantage as a woman
i think i'm i think as a young young
attractive women have an advantage over
young men yes i think so as well i think
so as well because like i don't know
women can call police over anything
and they'll get more aids than us what
do you think about the amber heard
johnny depp situation do you think that
kind of brings into the forefront the
the discrimination that feminism has
like had the last couple of years
because it was believe all women and
that that was the and now we're seeing
exactly and now we're seeing the
repercussions of that exactly that's
what i'm trying to say because like
women they get this this privilege that
they just need to say something and
the law is supposed to to be on their
side supposed to believe them just like
it happened with amber and johnny depp
like the guy got molested in everything
by his wife but just because she's a
woman first and second she's crying and
all of that people just start believing
her which is not and they gave her an
op-ed which is good they gave her an
op-ed with no proof which is crazy yeah
yeah she's still she still got out of
like 2 million but he'll go out of like
17 million or something so but yeah it's
not fair it's not fair to be honest well
thank you so much i appreciate you
sitting down um do you have any do you
have any here nice to meet you do you
have any um social medias you want to
plug we have a hundred thousand
subscribers yeah go ahead yeah well
uh instagram
youtube oh yeah i'll follow you but
you're not too far okay okay okay
okay
okay i didn't know some people plug
their social so thank you so much for
sitting down have a good one
yeah
agree disagree feel free to sit down
yeah yeah come on come on come on
[Music]
okay
hi what's your name gabriella gabriella
and um
would you consider yourself a feminist
no i'm surprised i've had so many people
come up and say they aren't feminists
why do you think that is
i don't know maybe they don't want to
look bad because if you say that you're
not a feminist then you're bad and so
when i went out to do interviews i
really was encouraged by how many people
actually agreed with me and didn't
believe in feminism or identify as a
feminist when i originally went out i
thought that everyone was gonna just
disagree and be mad but it was really
cool
to see that you know maybe not all
western women are lost
but i don't think i just don't want to
be associated with the word it doesn't
mean that i don't identify with some of
the things that feminists
say i just think there's a lot of like
prejudice
about feminism in general because of
yeah as you said like sometimes they get
very offended or like the attitude i
just don't like it
what do you think feminism is fighting
for in 2022
i mean they advocate for equality but
sometimes they
it's not really equality is it it's just
not very balanced
sometimes so
you know some things that you were
saying like i don't like that woman
wants so many rights but like a few
things that are
considered
normal in society like the man has to
pay for dinner or the man has to ask out
or
the man has to propose to a woman why
does it have to be like this like i i
don't agree with it i think that if you
really want equality you should have
equality in every field even if it's not
convenient for you you know
yeah and what um
what do you think about like the johnny
depp and amber heard situation
um do you feel like that was the fault
of feminism
i think amber heard definitely used
feminism in a bad way like for herself
and people at first sighted with her
only because she was a woman so they
uh
they assumed that she was right and
because the man is always a bad one
who's beating up woman and some people
don't realize that actually it can be
the other way around and thank god that
like uh
johnny actually won the the tryon and it
shows that you know
uh the justice system is right and they
see through you know people's lives and
things like that yeah yeah no i agree um
why don't you think we see um women
marching the street because
for men that aren't let into bars for
free
because they don't care it's not their
problem is it right yeah
they want equality don't they they want
equality for that like they want the
same things as men but they don't care
what men don't have and they have right
like what you said like women have
privilege sometimes because of their
looks um
they get hired in some places instead of
men maybe if there's a
if there's a man in charge they'll get
hired for their looks and i cannot say
that i'm not privileged because of my
looks obviously i know
i just tried to not use it in my
advantage you know i just tried to
be myself and you know use my
intelligence or something else as a
you know
tool let's say
okay where are you from london no where
are you from italy okay i i find that um
the more like
like eastern i guess in europe they
don't really agree with feminism as much
would you feel like that's true
i mean i don't know i guess it's not
such a big issue like we're not so
radical about it like obviously we want
to be equal but we are not
uh
marching down the streets or or making a
huge problem about it uh if a man
i don't know has more rights than us
like we just try to fight for it and uh
like even in our private lives you know
do you feel like
equality is possible with anyone like
even me and you we're both we're both
women right but me and you like we're
gonna be unequal in different things so
when people say equality i never know
what they're talking about
yeah because i guess it there's always a
third party that kind of sets the
standards right for equality so i guess
equality just means like same chances
and possibility for everyone but i don't
like to i don't even like the word
equality i think we were talking about
this with some friends i think
equality is never
the right word because people come from
different backgrounds different like
even economical situations so we don't
have the same possibilities so it's
almost like equality of opportunity
would be better than just equality
quality
it's i think
i don't remember the exact word we use
not equality we use like inclusion or
something like that yeah
well thank you so much i appreciate it
do you have any socials you want to plug
yes my instagram
it's at gabi underscore dmua my makeup
artist
thank you so much i appreciate it
you guys
i was really hoping to get somebody that
disagreed with me because at first
everyone that came up to me just agreed
with me all day
until dun dun dun
what's your name my name's nizana i'm
pearl nice to meet you
um would you identify as a feminist i
would say that i do yes okay so what do
you think we need feminism for in 2022
um so this girl demanded that she see
this video
the edits before i post it
um so this is just let me letting you
know that no um
you
decided to sit down
and get recorded you don't get to see
what i do with the footage
well in 2022 i think we need feminism
for the equality of all genders and all
sexes and
that's that really so what like like
what specific policy are we fighting for
equality of all sexes and the fact that
men have certain privileges that of
course women don't we don't have the
privilege of walking in the middle of
the night
and not being scared that someone's
going to attack us and
we're fighting for equality in those
terms and beyond that as well in terms
of you know in the legal world in terms
of uh education in terms of uh jobs
there's so many things that so to start
men are more likely to be victims of a
violent crime than women
so um
if like and i don't really know what
policy we'd be fighting for because i
think across the board like i i say
grape on youtube i can't say that
i can't say i can't say r-a-p-e on that
youtube so i'm gonna say grape okay like
grape is illegal murder is legal so all
violence is illegal so i just don't know
what policy we're fighting for because
if you just tell
bad guys don't don't grape or don't kill
like they're not going to stop but like
marches aren't going to fix that it's
just law enforcement yeah i agree i i'm
an aspiring barrister so i know that
more than anything it is the legal side
of things that
do need to be put in force more
i guess boldly and
solidly to in order for us to actually
achieve equality it's not a thing of oh
what is the one policy that's going to
make this work and that's going to that
what we're fighting for there's so many
things that feminism is fighting for and
you can't sort of box that into a
certain thing and say oh
what what is the one policy you're
fighting for i disagree with that it's
not it's not it's not one policy because
to me we are equal
like to me in 2022 i don't think we need
feminism because i don't think there's
anything left to fight for
well i would disagree with that and i
think i don't know where the
conversation would go from that other
than to say
that there are so many things
well so i'd like you to like list them
so so if women are at a disadvantage but
matt like because the first example you
gave men are more likely to be victims
of a violent crime so we're not
disadvantaged in that regard like men
men also are afraid to walk alone at
night in a dangerous area
take your point
but i think there's a certain privilege
of even us living in the western world
that you won't see beyond
just this island country there's so much
more that we haven't seen
in
uh south asian countries where my
parents originally from from
um african countries from south american
countries and a lot of it is to do with
education there is a clear disparity
between the education of
males to females and you don't see that
because we live here women dominate
colleges
yeah yeah so yeah but do an advantage
there but do they dominate colleges in
bangladesh do they dominate colleges in
india well but in any population group
it's never going to be equal like like
if you take okay if you take a group of
anyone it's never going to be 50 50 down
the middle because people have different
things that interest them yeah so yeah
so to me it's like if there's nothing in
their way stopping them from going to
school and and for me i'm specifically i
will sorry i should have prefaced with
this but i'm talking about like england
u.s because i'm american and and here
there's nothing stopping us from getting
an education
so so to me like what what's what's
holding us back
i mean
i think about
feminism as it also being intersectional
in this in the sense that i'm talking
about race i'm talking about class as
well socioeconomic divide in this
country
it's so clear okay so i just want us for
this conversation stick to gender
because that's like what we're talking
about because that's a whole nother yeah
but um because to me like i just don't
see anything holding us back there's
nothing i can't do
and like there are companies that have
done um
like google did a study on its employees
because they thought they were paying
women less but when they took into
account the number of hours worked and
the specific jobs that they had women
were making eight percent more and i
could quote you study after study after
study that that shows there's no pay gap
when you take in into the account hours
worked and interest
well
i don't like the fact that you're taking
one study out of i and i would love to
see that you know it bullet pointed and
written down in my own eyes but i don't
like uh just seeing oh from one company
and one this and one that because we
have to look at it in the entirety and
looking at in the end
and the entirety and even for example
for me i'm an aspiring barrister we're
all
self-employed what is that what is that
barrister is an advocate in court
they're a lawyer
and for example they're self-employed
but
in their chambers where they work they
don't have such thing as maternity pay
how are they meant to
fund themselves their their families
their children when they don't have
those policies in places and
that's where we disagree because you're
saying oh everything's good happy and
jolly but that's not the case is there
paternity pay
no there's so it's equal then
i would
disagree just because
i mean a woman has to literally shoot
someone out of their vagina
you know what i mean oh gosh it's
raining um
and i you know that is just one example
but what i'm trying to say is that they
we
look at a whole range of things and we
can see quite clearly that it's not
equal
well because like what i'd like to hear
from feminists is like what is the
specific problem and what do you
specifically propose lawmakers do about
it
i feel like it's so hard you're putting
me on the spot it's so hard to just kind
of get it up in my head because there
are so many things wrong i mean i mean
you know abortion and healthcare in
america that's
insane i don't want to delve into that
because it's just insanity i would say
compared to here we are blessed with the
nhs but
they can get abortions in america
but in certain states there's certain
conditions and there's certain
things that
had to be in order for someone to get an
abortion again i'm not i don't live in
the u.s i don't want to get well because
the one thing like like men aren't like
if women don't if i don't want to be a
mother i can get an abortion or drive to
a state that allows me to get an
abortion but if a man doesn't want to be
a father he can't he can't he's he's
stuck on child support for 18 years
he can't he can't opt out of being a
father the way that women can opt out of
being a mother i have a question for you
i pray choice of
am i am i pro-choicer pro-life oh i'm
pro-life
yeah i can see quite clearly um sorry
what was your question so i'm saying
like i i i would say that in in terms of
reproduction men are at the disadvantage
because if i if i get pregnant right
let's say let's see um there's a guy i
get pregnant and he doesn't want me to
keep the baby he has no say
and on top of that so he he he's stuck
on child support for 18 years
where where me i i can cash a check
there are women that are that are
seeking out hot top individuals like nba
players like trying to get pregnant by
them because the justice system is so
in favor of women like i just have to
get you know i just have to get pregnant
by a dude and i'm entitled to his money
for 18 years
you know what you're
the way you're twisting things is
actually reminding me of how the media
twists everything in the sense like you
take the one percent of the cases that
are happening and i and i want to say i
disagree with the whole nba thing but a
woman's body is her body she can choose
to do whatever the [ __ ] she wants with
that it's not necessarily a guy's choice
to say hey
i bought the baby because i don't want
it no that's that's your bit that's not
your business it's a woman's body it's
my body i'm going to birth but it's his
baby
you're the one that had sex with the
woman that's your fault you you fought
for having sex with him
no you can't say that just because no
we're talking you said it the other way
around okay fair enough i would take
your point but i'm saying
you can't say the whole point of oh just
because the man doesn't want the baby
it's not his body to choose whatever the
hell he wants with it question would you
agree that it's his money his choice so
he should if he says i don't want to be
a father and the woman says i want to be
a mother he can financially
be like do a financial abortion where
he's not on the hook for child support
would you agree with that be in the name
of equality oh i i would if if the if
that is an agreement between both
parties then of course
no no where she says i want his child
support and he says
no
like i don't want to give it to you so
should he be because a woman
i have if i get pregnant i have the
option to say i don't want to be a
mother but if i get pregnant he doesn't
have the option to say i don't want to
be a father
so you're asking
so if the woman
says hey i want your money and the guy
says no i don't want to give it to you
oh that would be a difficult one i'll
probably have to give a bit of a think
on that i haven't ever thought about it
and i don't want to give my opinion
without validly sort of backing it up um
so yeah give that a think
because i'm just like this is what i
mean when i say feminism is a hate group
because we only advocate for for women
and in that case like in my head it
should be pretty cut and dry
because
like if if a woman gets to choose not to
be a mother then a man should be able to
choose not to be a father
i'm going to go back to the point of
view saying feminism is a hate group i
think
that in and of itself
is not what feminism is of course as any
feminist would argue but
how
everyone perceives feminism i guess
that's in their own eyes what they see
on social media but how i perceive
feminism is to be inequality
of everyone equality of sex is of
quality of gender so
it's not the superior superiority of
women which i think that's your angle
into this
i never said women are better than men
it's more so hey i would love to have
the same rights as you
that's literally it well to me we have
the same rights if not more especially
in the legal system because men get
three times the amount of sentencing for
the same crime as a woman and right now
we're seeing the effects with amber
heard and johnny depp believe all women
like look look where that got us that
was that was at the cost of of men
because if a man that has privilege and
power that happened to him
what happened to the average guy oh no i
i agree with the amber her try i think
that's a difficult
case to kind of look at just because
yeah um
i know in terms of american law it kind
of makes it easier now for
uh no sorry it makes it harder now for
women to have no evidence or
yeah so i know where you're coming from
in terms of that but sorry
back to your question again would you
agree that the um that in that case
feminism was at the detriment of men
because that was specifically during the
believe all women
era well i don't understand so so my
question is in that instance the amber
heard and johnny depp would you agree
that feminism was at the detriment of
men
because that was during the believe all
woman era yeah um
i wouldn't say feminism was i think
i think in terms of the amber trial i
would say it kind of routes back to more
the criminal justice system than it is
to do with feminism in in the sense that
i mean i believe all women
are able to have a voice and
can be a complainant in a case and be
fairly tried it's not the sense of hey
we should all believe her i never
thought hey we should all believe her we
should all believe him
but it wasn't in the justice system like
that like you can't say it was like the
justice system because um like what
happened was she got an op-ed
so it was just a mat it was like a it
was a left-leaning magazine that gave
her
an opinion editorial with no evidence
and was able to assassinate his
character with no evidence because we
should believe all women
no that's what i'm saying i i can't go
too much into that just because
um well i can't i don't know
insanely too much about it to be fair um
but no i i do agree that if there's no
evidence that gay someone then okay so
we agree on that yeah the one thing yeah
but again like i said with that it's
very hard because
in terms of that my opinion is just
every every woman every man should be
heard in the justice system the criminal
justice system and they should be fairly
tried and it's not the case of amber oh
sorry uh johnny depp winning they both
you know they both had to pay damages it
was more so that johnny depp i was just
awarded more damages it wasn't a
criminal traversal we can't say anything
in terms of that sorry my legal nuzzana
is coming out
so my other question if feminism is
about equality why don't you see women
marching the streets for men to get into
bars for free or for male only fans
models to get the same amount of pay
like we see for sorry i'm sorry like we
see for um the women's soccer team
i think the least of our worries is
about men getting into clubs for free
you know honesty i think there's so much
more that we have to fight for that
that's the most
i don't know fickle thing ever so i i
would say no comment to that just
because that's a ridiculous question
well what about modeling let's take like
the modeling industry it's very much
favorite like women get paid more in the
modeling industry than that but we we
don't see any marches for that where
with um the women's soccer team they're
they're
it's a big commotion about them getting
paid the same
i think i would revert this question
more so back to again this being one
case scenario so i i don't know the
evidence behind it but i i can imagine
that why women get paid more is because
there's a higher demand for them but i
could also argue oh what's happening at
wall street what's happening at canary
wharf what's happening at transfer lane
who uh there's clearly a gender
disparity there where i work gosh you'd
hardly see a woman at the highest
authority or the highest uh stage in our
career
so i do not say that to you as well so
again it's a wrong do you know why that
is though what do you mean why why
there's more men
because they have more they have male
privilege in the fact that
they're able to go through life in many
stages without having to worry about
certain things even as like an ethnic
person a woman has to take care of her
family
there are certain barriers that you just
don't see
in
i don't know in like a western world
wouldn't you say it's women choosing
what they want to choose so if women if
more women choose to be mothers and more
men choose to go after one percent jobs
like why is that a bad thing like why do
we need to fight for equality if women
are choosing what they want to choose
that's not i'm not saying that's a bad
thing women can choose whatever they
want to do men can choose whatever they
want to do it's more so the fact that
the the aspiring women and the aspiring
men even if it was a 50 50 ratio it's
going to end up at the top it being
maybe 20 women 80 men because that's
just how the system works but i don't
i'm saying i don't think it's the system
like my so i'll give you an example my
dad
he's he's in the one percent right in
terms of income but he worked 80 hours a
week my whole life i didn't see him i
don't know many women that want to work
80 hour weeks like like 12 hour days
every single day for 20 30 years like i
think most women have a natural
inclination to want to be with their
family yeah no that's fair enough but
also there are women that are like that
there are women that want to be the top
10 there are women that don't mind
working 80 hours a week but they don't
have the opportunity to get there in the
first place what so what opportunity do
they not have they're they're hiring
quotas that specifically they want to
hire women over men
even with hiring quotas i don't
necessarily agree with it because it's
almost so much for
i don't know so much for
i don't know how to describe it other
than it's not really it doesn't have
oh i don't know how to say it um
i don't know i don't think quotas are
enough is probably what i'm trying to
say so so what would be enough
genuinely giving women the i wouldn't
even say benefit of the doubt but where
credit is due and allowing them to work
their way up the
system really how are we not giving
credit when we hear women's empowerment
all the time i never hear men's
empowerment
well we need women empowerment in the
world in in this world because
i mean i don't want to keep arguing well
at the same point but obviously we're
not agreeing on this then other than the
fact that women
are disadvantaged in this world and
that's what we're fighting for is the
equality it's not the superiority
well i i just don't like because i just
feel like you you you keep saying we're
disadvantaged but you don't give me
specific examples of how we're
disadvantaged okay well i'll have you
i'll message you on instagram when i
actually have a clear head and i'm not
really extremely heated
okay no worries um do you have anything
any channels you want to plug anything
um
i have an instagram it's at legalnasana
that's l-e-g-a-l-n-i-z-a-n-a
that's it okay well thank you for
sitting down i appreciate having like
respectful conversations with people
that disagree so i really appreciate you
sitting and stopping thank you okay to
learn more about your view than it'd be
but i do appreciate it okay okay
anyone yeah anyone agree disagree
have you seen my channel
did you did you see my instagram post or
did you just no no it's walking
oh okay okay
okay so what's your name uh key
um and what do you think about feminism
i think it's different now okay i think
there i think that a lot of uh maybe
first and second wave feminists might
not agree with the new wave right now in
terms of how
things are being uh done and what
they're fighting for and not being able
to necessarily support in the same way
like by what they actually say you know
i mean i feel like a lot of a lot of
things are said right now
that are not actual beliefs but also
talking points that sort of disrupt the
idea of communication and conversation
so it gets a bit hard to actually have a
genuine
conversation so yeah
um
what you know what's interesting i'm
going to show you this step um did you
know in 1848 and in the late 1800s and
1900s um feminists were
bombing churches and planning
assassination
okay didn't know that so it's all like
to me it's always been a it's always
been a hate group why is why is it
what is it define define a hate group
that's a good question i i i think they
feminists want privileges at the cost of
men
[Music]
yeah yeah um i also think that
most people
that fight for anything would do it at
the cost of
uh anything as long as it supports what
they believe yeah so but i hear you
that's interesting
because to me it's just like they scream
equality so i just i just want to see
yeah yeah yeah that is one thing but i
think that equality
i think the argument for equality is one
that isn't uh it's nuanced surely right
and i think that it depends on what you
mean by equality and right what what
needs to actually be equal versus what
needs to be uh what's the word
based on merit for example right you
know and if it actually makes sense for
certain people to be in certain
positions
do you think that women need feminism in
2022
i think
i don't know because i don't think i
don't think feminism i don't think
feminism is it's the same thing i think
it's different i think it depends on
what you define feminism as and i think
that's one of the issues of feminist
holders
um
i think yeah i think feminism means
different things different people
nowadays and
depending on who you're talking to
you get a different answer so i don't
know if we need the
uh
very particular
view that feminism has right now that is
essentially
equality equality equality until
equality means men having something yeah
maybe it's this weird sort of like
yeah we want equality but not not if men
get something instead of women and i
think that's a bit it's a bit weird to
say that you can't you can't scream
equality and not actually be about
equality do you think men since women
have the option not to be mothers like
they can get like so so if you get a
girl pregnant right she has the option
to get an abortion do you think that men
should get the option to have a
financial abortion yeah yeah i do i do i
truly do but i wouldn't frame it in that
way but i think that that if you
actually
have a choice in the matter i think
that's quite important and i think that
men don't really get the opportunity to
have a choice in the matter and um yeah
that needs to change
well thank you so much for sitting down
i appreciate it
i thought this man was very nice
and i liked his outfit
should i sit closer so you don't have to
can't you a little bit closer thank you
god
oh my gosh we just can't be giving this
out okay so um
what do you think that feminism is a
hate crime
so i was actually
standing here thinking about that and
in a certain sense i agree
but not
the first thought i had was yeah this is
hatred towards men blah blah but
actually i think it's not that i think
it's
i i sense in modern feminism a certain
amount of hatred towards
femininity
you know like i think about what is it
that a lot of feminism over the last 30
years is about and it seems very much
about
having the kind of power
prestige and sort of the the picture of
success
that men
haven't created
rather than
the
kind of feminine version and picture of
success
why do you think that is
well i
i guess it's
it's a movement that at its foundation
seems to
really
derive in in the political sphere and so
obviously if you're
a party in the political sphere
you know you're going to be going after
political power
not
um
oh
the public life that's not important
it's the private life that's important
let's
i mean that that wouldn't be a very
successful political uh
position
certainly wouldn't get you a lot of
power and votes so if it if that was a
movement of some part of feminism
and and you know i'm sure there is a
part of feminism like that and in the
nordics like there's there's a lot more
actually women choosing to stay at home
and you know with with kind of you know
quite a lot of free choice
uh but i would guess that that
part of the movement would probably not
be
the most ambitious in driving and
grabbing votes and pushing other people
kind of to the side and winning because
it's not a very sharp elbow kind of
position it's it's more about like yeah
no like
you know your relationships at home with
your family with your extended family
with your community that's what matters
don't worry about what's going on in
berlin in london in washington that's
kind of not what matters in life
why do you think it's okay for women to
say men are trash but it's not okay for
men to say women are [ __ ]
well i think you see that in
uh many of the dichotomies uh you know
from like probably going back to like
communist stuff where there was like oh
the people who
build the businesses they're rubbish but
the people who work in the businesses
they're great and you know now there's a
whole black white divide
so i mean it just happens everywhere
where you have very militant groups and
why is it okay
um
yeah
i i don't know
how that came about i think it's a real
shame i think it's preposterous and i
think when we look back on it in a
certain time hopefully people will go
how is that not sexist racist classist
etc
do you think that men should be able to
have
a since women have the right to choose
um in the uk it's abortions legal up to
six months do you think that
men should have a say to have a
financial abortion where they don't have
to pay child support
because women have the choice not to be
a mother can he have the choice not to
be a father
in the name of equality
no i don't think so okay i think i think
that
i think you you
i mean that's one to really contemplate
i'm sure there's some scenarios where it
but no overall i think
you know whether whatever kind of
accident or decision making power you
had you know it's you've done it and
now you're
you have an obligation to that right do
you agree with women having the right to
choose
i do
don't you think that that favors women
though and not men
because if if i wanted to then i could
go get pregnant by a rich guy and then i
have i have a check for 18 years
i think it takes some part of him doing
something as well no i i agree um but
you have you have like cases where like
there's entire reddit threads where
women are just trying to figure out how
to get pregnant by men
and it's almost like the laws allow
women to be predatory yeah
well
i don't think we should infantilize men
or anybody you know we're adults and we
take decisions we get into bed with
somebody and
that's i i agree i just don't think a
woman should be entitled to a man's
money
like i think we i can work like why why
do you why are you entitled to his money
for 18 years
shouldn't it be 50 50 custody like why
which that should be like the from the
off the bat and no money
well i'm not it is still gendered but
it's not entirely gendered i know cases
where
the woman's the you know
very wealthy chef and she's paying money
to uh you know some
okay i mean i i would agree i agree both
ways like i don't i don't think child
support should be i was just curious
what your opinion was though
i think there should be an obligation
and yeah you know as a as a man who's
part of this or a woman you know you're
you're in on something that is going to
last for you know 18 20 years and you
need to spend money do you think people
should be more careful with who they
sleep with
i'm no person to comment on that but
send a comment on that
okay um
where
okay where is the justice for the people
that said
what do you think of the phrase believe
all women
[Music]
well i think it i think we have gone
very much
to the extreme uh recently
where
somebody's life can be completely undone
through mere accusation
and
i think that power doesn't need to be
curbed in some way
hopefully we'll find a balance in the
next whatever yeah
i hope so too thank you so much for
sitting down you're really fun to talk
to
i appreciate it